(birds chirping)
(gentle music playing)
- I'm looking into North Korea
for the first time in my life
and it's kind of surreal.
I'm up here on a rooftop,
and I'm seeing two giant flag poles.
(gentle music playing)
I mean, that is a massive flag pole.
You go over this wall,
and you're not actually
in North Korea yet.
You're in a no man's land,
a four-mile-thick demilitarized zone
that effectively comprises the border.
I came to this border
because I want to understand
this in a new way.
I'm tired of watching this.
- The intensifying
showdown with North Korea.
- The North Koreans
are in no mood to talk.
They're in the mood of
testing and blowing things up.
- Getting one very
specific version fed to me
about what this conflict is about.
- Rogue regime (indistinct)
- Nuclear testing is a big deal.
- Another nuclear test at any time.
- Who it's between, why it exists.
- The missile that North Koreans launched
is something the US has never seen before.
- Kim's stockpile of nuclear weapons.
- Capable of hitting the
continental United States.
- Instead I want to see it for myself,
to talk to the people who
live in South Korea's capital,
a city of 10 million people
that is 40 kilometers
from this border.
I hear there's a lot of bomb shelters
and so I want to go see
what those look like.
So I want to show you
this peculiar border,
what it looks like, what it feels like,
and most importantly, how it got here.
(fast music playing)
Not fed through western diplomacy,
military policy and media coverage,
but rather what it actually
looks like on the ground.
(fast music playing)
(gentle music playing)
I'm drowning in some
of the coolest evidence
I've ever touched in my life
which are original
telegrams between Stalin
and Kim Il-Sung.
I've got a ton of this stuff, and frankly,
it's very, very useful for
understanding this border,
this line that divided
the Korean Peninsula.
What I first need to do
is thank today's sponsor
who made this ambitious video possible.
CoPilot is a platform where
you get paired with a fitness
coach one-on-one.
It's like a personalized coach,
and you get to craft a fitness
plan that works for you.
I went through the whole
process of getting paired up
with a coach.
Hey Donny, it's a pleasure to meet you.
- Is there any injury, things or pains
that I need to be cognizant of?
- Then I got to have my first workout.
It shows me what I'm supposed to do.
The best part about this is
that it's tailored to my life.
Like what I can actually do,
how much time I actually
want to spend doing this?
CoPilot makes it so much
easier to fit exercise
into your life.
- What are you using?
- I forgot my dumbbells,
so I'm using the sandbags
here in the studio.
So much of what we hear
about fitness is focused on
transforming how you look.
What I love about CoPilot,
it's about consistent movement
to improve how you feel,
how your mind works and what
you can do with your body.
I am so in line with those values.
After a workout,
I could let them know if something was off
or if I wanted to change the focus.
Workout was good today,
I do wish that there was more.
And I could get a response
with additional feedback
being implemented into future
workouts.
You get unlimited back
and forth in app texting
with your coach and
unlimited video calls like
it's really amazing.
So if this sounds interesting to you,
you can get 14 days for free
with your own expert fitness,
and health coach at the
link in my description.
It's go.mycopilot.com/JohnnyHarris.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel as always,
but it also gets you in on
this deal of two weeks for free
to start your journey with CoPilot.
I've loved it and I think you will too.
So with that,
let's get back to North Korea.
This line, this peninsula,
we've all heard something about it.
I studied this line a lot in
college and in grad school
at the think tank I worked at.
But for this story,
I wanted to throw out
all of that training,
all of that perspective.
I wanted to approach it with a new lens,
one not steeped in the
assumptions and biases
of American foreign policy,
media and military thinking.
So let me show you my new
perspective on how this line
came to be.
Korea was an independent,
unified place until the early
1900s when Japan annexed
it as part of their conquest of Asia.
Then the world responded
beating them back and crushing
this growing empire.
That's World War II.
The winners of the war got
together and decided that yes,
we just liberated Korea from Japan.
But no, they are not ready
to be independent just yet.
The two most powerful allies
decided that they would each
occupy half of the peninsula
for up to five years.
Then Koreans could have
one independent country,
this whole peninsula.
Most Koreans, of course,
hated this more colonizers
using their peninsula
as a military base, but the
great powers didn't really care.
So late one night in 1945,
right before Japan surrendered,
two US military leaders got
together here in the Pentagon
and pulled out this map.
This map actually.
This is a 1942 National Geographic map
that these two military
leaders used to split Korea.
They eyeballed this peninsula
and they proposed this line
here at 38 North.
It's like a latitude line.
And surprisingly to
them, the Soviets agreed.
- 38 parallel border of North Korea.
- With this line the Americans
were trying to get Seoul,
which was Korea's capital
on their side of the line,
which they did by just like 40 kilometers.
Oh, and just to be clear here, this line,
the 30th parallel wasn't
some natural border.
It wasn't a linguistic or cultural border.
But again, the whole idea was that
this was just going to be temporary.
It's going to last five years.
Two great powers dividing
land with maps temporarily.
What could go wrong?
Okay, so what's the deal
with the Soviet Union,
and the United States in this moment?
You have to remember that they were allies
after World War II,
because they had fought a
common enemy banding together
to crush the Nazi empire in Europe.
And then the Soviets
joined in over here in Asia
kind of last second to
help deal the final blows
to the Japanese empire.
So these two superpowers were friends.
I mean, I have direct proof of this.
Check out a picture of my
grandpa in the late forties
on the Korean peninsula.
He's standing right up here on the border
between the Soviet Union and Korea,
and he's hanging out
with the Soviet soldier
with a big smile on his face.
The Soviets and Americans were allies,
they were friends, they
had worked together here.
But very quickly they started
to realize how much they
actually weren't friends
and that they thought very
differently about how
the world should work.
And in fact, now that other big
empires were out of the way,
the entire world was now a
chessboard open for them to make
their moves to ensure that their ideology
would become the new way of the world.
Yes, we want to give Korea
back to the Koreans said,
the Soviet Union and the United States,
but will it be an American
friendly capitalist society
or a Soviet friendly communist society?
Meanwhile, the local Koreans,
at least most of them
were hating all of this.
But there was one Korean
who was not hating it,
the new leader of the Soviet
backed North Kim Il-Sung,
who was a war guy,
he rose up as a fighter in
China's communist revolution
and was picked to then lead
the communist part of Korea.
Kim wanted to unite the
peninsula under communism
with force,
but he couldn't do that without
the blessing of his Soviet
supporters, mainly this guy Joseph Stalin.
And this is where the evidence
we found gets pretty juicy.
- Among communists.
Kim is the last to maintain
a personality cult.
- Okay, check these out.
These are telegrams and
conversations between Joseph Stalin
and Kim Il-Sung.
I mean, this is like when
you are looking at original
conversations in the original
text from these great leaders,
which have since been
declassified by the presidential
archives in Moscow.
You learn more from this
than you do from any textbook
or any master's degree
because this is like the horse's mouth.
This is what they were actually saying.
You start to get the first
insights into how the Cold War
would start to play out.
The logic, the calculations,
the fears, the goals.
Okay, so it's 1949.
Kim Il-Sung immediately goes
to Stalin asking for support
and weapons to invade the south,
to unite the peninsula
under the communist flag.
Not surprisingly Stalin is
very interested in communism
winning out on the Korean peninsula.
But you read these conversations
and you see that he's also
kind of freaked out.
The Americans are there,
and a direct conflict with these
two superpowers is a recipe
for another global war.
Plus China, which is
another communist ally,
is currently in a big civil war.
They're not going to be able
to help Kim out in his efforts.
So Stalin basically says no.
But then the next year, 1950
three big things change.
(suspense music playing)
Stalin sends a note to
Kim saying he's quote,
"ready to help him in this matter,"
tells him to come to Moscow.
Thing number one,
Stalin got intel from one
of his spies in Washington
that South Korea wasn't that
important to the Americans.
And if that there was an invasion,
the Americans probably
wouldn't do anything.
US troops were leaving the peninsula.
Thing number two,
and this is a big freaking deal.
Stalin says it right here,
that quote, "the USSR
now has the atomic bomb"
ending, the US' atomic monopoly.
That changes everything.
And thing number three,
and again, we see this
in another conversation.
Stalin says to Kim,
in one of these meetings,
the communist in China had
just won their civil war.
They control China now.
They're not busy with the Civil War,
and they'll be able to help
with an invasion of South Korea.
With these three major developments,
Stalin now feels secure
that the US won't come
to "challenge the communists in Asia."
It would be an easy victory.
Oh, and at the end of
all these conversations,
Stalin is like, side
note, we will support you,
we will give you weapons,
but we're not going to send troops.
Go ask Mao for those, which
is exactly what he did.
So do you see what's happening here?
This is like Cold War like crash course.
It is spies.
Prevailing mood is not
to interfere in the US.
It is global ideological alliances.
China's victory is also
important psychologically.
And it is nuclear deterrence.
The USSR now has the atomic bomb.
The seeds of the Cold War are sprouting.
- After three years of preparation,
the Soviet Union and its North
Korean propers were ready.
Troops and military equipment
poured down from the north.
- So then early one
morning in June of 1950,
it happened some 75,000
soldiers from the north blast
across this line,
a line that two American military
guys had drawn five years
earlier.
- June 25th, 1950, the communist strike.
- And as Kim Il-Sung predicted,
his troops quickly took over
nearly the entire peninsula.
But Stalin's calculation was wrong.
Back in Washington,
President Truman wasn't going
to let the communist take over
the Korean peninsula.
- The future of civilization
depends on what we do,
on what we do now.
- He got ready for war,
bypassing Congress to prepare
to get a bunch of UN nations
together to come to Korea's rescue.
- Like obstacles,
United Nations forces drive
on to the 38th parallel
border of North Korea.
- The details of what
happened next are astounding,
and frankly, I have no
idea why I didn't learn
these details in school.
This was a brutal and long
war, incredibly destructive.
The entire peninsula was ripped apart,
but an important detail for this story
is what the US Air force
did up here in the north.
- The versatility of Air Forces
was proved as never before.
- With their new jet powered aircraft.
They quickly established
air superiority and dropped
an unfathomable amount of
explosives onto North Korea.
Like it's hard to quantify,
but to put it into perspective,
the US Air Force dropped
more bombs on North Korea
in this three year period than
they did during the entire
Pacific Theater of World War II.
- After identifying their targets,
our planes swooped down like avenging,
shadows of death and destruction.
- The US Air Force targeted
basically anything that moved,
villages, towns, buildings, factories,
and very importantly dams.
- US carrier based planes take off,
their target the vital
hydroelectric power plants
south of the Yalo River.
- Unleashing a flood of water
that washed away villages
and killed the water supply to
rice and other crops leading
to an excruciatingly slow
starvation of the people
who started living in a
network of underground caves
to escape the bombardment
of their country.
- An advance whose purpose
general Richway states is not
to seize ground, but
to wipe out the enemy.
- In the end,
85% of all buildings in
North Korea were destroyed.
85%.
- Communists have finally
launched they're undeclared,
all out war of conflict.
- Now, wait, I know what you're
thinking if you're familiar
with this conflict, which is
that this entire peninsula
got slammed.
It wasn't just the north,
the north and the south.
Seoul was turned to dust as well.
This was a horrifying war.
The reason I'm highlighting
the utter destruction,
and the aerial bombardment of the north
is because what the US Air Force did here,
this memory became a foundational
memory for these people.
It would go on to inform the
rest of the country's history
to this day.
This memory would not fade.
This horrific war went on
for three years until 1953
when they signed a ceasefire
freezing the frontline
of the war where it was on the
day they signed right here.
The agreement was to take this
line and put a two kilometer
buffer on each side,
declaring it a zone where no
military activity can occur.
A de-militarized zone.
So where I'm standing now
is the de-militarized zone,
the DMZ.
No military stuff allowed
within this four kilometer thick
buffer zone up here, North
Korea, down here, South Korea,
and these borders are
some of the most fortified
and militarized lines on our planet.
After the war, the American
military never went home,
and since then, there have been
tens of thousands of troops
on this peninsula.
Oh, and crucially,
the US stored nuclear
weapons on this peninsula
during the Cold War,
providing South Korea with the
security they needed to turn
into a thriving, advanced democracy,
helping them build their country
to move on from the trauma
and pain of this war.
And like I said earlier,
North Korea did the opposite.
They didn't move on.
They stayed fixated on what
happened during those three
years of horror,
continuing to build up
anti-aircraft defenses,
underground bunkers and tunnels.
And over the course of decades,
their Soviet supporters
helped them learn the science
of nuclear energy that by 2006
turned into nuclear weapons.
North Korea becoming the eighth
country to possess the most
destructive weapons in the world.
And as the Soviet Union
collapsed and cut off all of its
support, North Korea used
this one weapon to stay
in the conversation
to ensure that they would
never find themselves
in this situation again.
(gentle music playing)
As one historian from
Columbia University said.
North Korea never forgot the lessons
of their vulnerability
from American airstrikes,
and that the long term
psychological effects
of the war on the whole
of North Korean society
cannot be overestimated.
The war against the United
States more than any other single
factor, gave North Koreans a
collective sense of anxiety,
and fear of outside threats
that would continue long after
the wars end.
North Korea keeps this
memory alive through horrific
imagery.
There's actually a museum
just south of Pongy
that's dedicated to the
atrocities committed
by the United States.
You walk into this place and
it is full of horrific imagery
like paintings of Americans
doing terrible things
to North Koreans.
I'm not going to show you
any of this propaganda here
because it is gruesome and horrifying.
Oh and the target audience of this museum,
Children.
Every year young children make
a pilgrimage to this museum
to witness these images
and affirm in their minds
their hatred for the United States,
and their desire for revenge
Keeping alive this memory from the 1950s.
The regime keeps this memory
alive to keep their people
scared and oppressed,
constantly ready for war.
Back in Seoul.
Every few years,
North Korea comes out and
says that they are ready
and willing to turn this
city into a sea of fire
or a pile of ashes,
and frankly, they have the tools to do it.
Up here on this border,
there are over 10,000
big military guns pointed
at this city.
These guns have a range
of over 60 kilometers,
which put Seoul very much in range.
Luckily, people in this city are ready.
There are over 3000
bomb shelters sprinkled
throughout Seoul, and that is
what I'm looking for today.
Luckily, the government made
an app to show the people
of Seoul where all of
these bomb shelters are.
Wait, this is the bomb shelter.
I mean, I guess we're underground,
but like barely.
I got to talk to one of these shop owners,
see what they think.
Did you know that this
was a bomb shelter,?
I guess is the question.
(speaking Korean)
- That one was just a shopping mall.
Come on, let's go
somewhere else on the map.
Wait, so the next bomb shelter
on this map is a Starbucks.
What?
So did you know that
there's a bomb shelter over?
- I didn't know that.
I've never noticed that.
- So this is it.
This is the bomb shelter.
The basement of this apartment complex.
Let's go visit another one I guess.
We've reached another shelter.
Now I'm really in a bomb shelter.
Oh, actually it's just
another parking garage.
What is this?
If we had to rush down
here, is there water?
Is there extra food?
Is there some way to seal it
off so that chemical weapons
don't get down here? No.
It's literally an
unchanged parking garage.
Not retrofitted, not special in any way.
I'm starting to lose faith
in the idea that these bomb
shelters are anything but just
normal city infrastructure
that have signs on them that
say, these are bomb shelters.
Do these people not realize
they live 40 kilometers
from North Korea?
- I'm making a video about sort
of the American perspective,
of North Korea, which is like.
Have you ever thought
through like a scenario
of like what you would
do in case of an attack?
- Oh.
- No.
- You don't.
(speaking Korean)
- I've actually never thought about it.
- We just hate the regime and oh my God.
I can't do this.
I hate pigeons so much.
- Are you more afraid of
pigeons than North Korea?
- Yeah.
Where were we?
- We were talking about.
As I told you,
I've lived here for my whole
life and I've seen them like
testing nuclear weapons,
but like we don't really care.
- Now listen, let me just be frank,
I'm slightly playing up my ignorance here.
I kind of knew that this was the case,
but I also kind of didn't,
as an American who studied this conflict
through an American foreign policy lens,
my hunt for bomb shelters and
the subsequent conversations
with locals drove home just
how little the people here
actually think about North Korea.
- I don't think I've ever met
anyone in Korea who was like
really worried about that.
(speaking Korean)
- Kim Jong-un doesn't do
this to threaten South Korea.
They do this to threaten
us, the United States,
the military that turned
their country into dust
in the 1950s,
the country that they are
technically still at war with.
Back up here at the border,
you can see what the conflict
actually looks like today
between north and south.
There's occasional violence,
but the conflict today
is often more petty.
Who can build the largest flag pole?
Who can blast the loudest
music at each other?
North Korea comically building
a fake city to look more
prosperous and a competition
of who can look the scariest.
You realize that it's not
actually scary or threatening
to be here.
If anything, it's just plain sad.
It's sad to see 70 years of this standoff,
this needless standoff that was created
by powerful outsiders.
And once again,
what we see is that the people
who share the same history,
and culture and language, but are divided,
continue to be the ones
that suffer from this.
(birds chirping)
After my time in the DMZ,
I decided to set aside the
history, the bluster, the fear,
just for a moment to
experience this place.
Not as an American taught
to see this region purely
in terms of conflict,
but to experience it as the
people here experience it.
The people here in this
city that is unrecognizable
from the devastation of the 50s,
a city that has moved on.
It is a Saturday night
here in Seoul South Korea,
the sun is going down.
I spent the night traversing this city,
immersing myself in what it has to offer,
from the nightclubs to barbecue,
to small underground clubs,
watching DJ competitions and sipping soju.
Then to a street party in
the middle of the night
where a bunch of young
people are protesting
the forced eviction and planned demolition
of this historic pub,
One of Seoul's oldest institutions
for beer and dried fish.
They've been doing this
every night for months.
Yes, North Korea is 40 kilometers away.
I'm very aware of that.
There's a real threat here,
a dangerous oppressive
regime with powerful weapons.
But the threat presents very
differently for the people
here, much differently
than the fear that we feel
an ocean away.
I walked away from Korea with
a much clearer understanding
of this conflict.
This conflict that was
started by North Korea,
fueled by Cold War dynamics
and remains an active war
between North Korea and the
United States of America.
(gentle music playing)
Thank you for watching this video.
I'm really looking
forward to your thoughts.
And once again,
I want to thank the
sponsor of today's video.
I'm two weeks into my
journey with CoPilot,
this platform that allows me
to have one on one interaction
with a fitness coach.
And I can tell you it is
making a giant difference
in just accountability.
And I'm not alone in this,
CoPilot clients are nine
times more successful
at sticking with their goals,
and that's not surprising to me.
So go click link in my
description to get 14 days free
with your own expert
fitness and health coach.
Thank you CoPilot for
supporting this video.
Thank you all for watching.
I will see you in the next one.
Okay.
(gentle piano music playing)